you have to drive fast to artillery
positions around Bahamut clear summer
Skies make it easier for Russian
reconnaissance or so-called Kamikaze
drones to home in on Ukrainian positions
and Military movement
Ukrainian artillery fires close by and
we are ordered to run to the bunker
inside Are Soldiers with Ukraine's 80
Air Assault Brigade
they're targeting Russian positions to
the south of bakmut to assist their
infantry which they say is advancing
gradually North as they try to retake
territory lost in recent weeks
guys from our assault unit have made
some progress in some places mostly from
the south of bakmud if we see targets
particularly infantry or lightly armored
enemy Vehicles we hit them so our
assault units can take enemy positions
more easily
drones feed live pictures of Russian
positions Yvonne waits for the order
from a central command post to fire
a soviet-built artillery piece is hidden
under trees
we're trying to ration our ammunition we
cannot use more than six shells on a
single Target we are around about 90
successful but it takes more than six to
fully destroy a Target another gun takes
over a few minutes later the order is
given
we have to move back under cover quickly
before Russian Artillery replies
what Ukrainian forces are trying to do
here is soften up Targets in and around
as part of the beginnings of this
counter-offensive
and they say that they are progressing
from the south
advancing around a kilometer a week
back inside the bunker Ivan watches the
screen and says that he sees the shells
hit their target
the target was 100 meters from our
positions we try to operate with
Precision the first shell landed
slightly above the target but after
correction the second was a direct hit
Ukrainian force is a probing for weak
points in Russian defenses in various
locations along the near 1 000 kilometer
front line
as the long expected counter-offensive
begins
Charles Trafford Al Jazeera near bakmut
let's get the view from Russia now